jouer les indignés temps vous voulez
mais pardonnez moi un moment donné de
vous remettre à votre place monsieur
blachier vous n'êtes ni autorités
sanitaires et encore moins effectivement
autorités danoises
pourquoi ne vous parle pas à vous
[Musique]
souhaiter beaucoup d'ennemis verse à son
tour histoire
vous n'avez ce soir est dorénavant que
mon pur mépris je suis désolée et
regrettait fait que vous méprisez même
quand même vous rappeler que le danemark
vous explique vous expliqué xavier maman
qu'une enquête approfondie doit être
menée là exactement ils disent par très
caution et là vous vous dites e10 par
très caution disons doit mener enquête
et on attend les résultats de l'enquêté
quoique le lien de causalité soit
improbable mais non nécessaire à ce
stade pour suspendre et non intégral ça
n'arrivera pas rappelez vous de ce qui
m'a dit monsieur rappelez vous de ceux
qui ont dit ça n'arrivera pas dernier
qu'ils ont dit vous avez raison ce
ministre de la santé et un an plus tard
de 70 mille morts et en chantant mois
pour une fois je suis d'accord avec m
des bisous pour une fois ils écrasent
qui dit et pour une fois il se
positionnait il ya une différence entre
suggéré aux gens de se faire vacciner et
forcer les gens à se faire vacciner et
pardon moi à titre personnel conjointe
ya des pays qui suspend de la
vaccination
et quand je vois qu'il ya des problèmes
avec ce vaccin c'est pas la première
polémique même si on n'a pas beaucoup
dézoné ça me fait flipper et j'ai pas
envie de me faire vacciner avec
astrazeneca vire à dinan m division je
voudrais vous poser une question si
jamais dans quinze jours le danemark dit
les autorités de santé danois disent ok
alors il n'y a aucun lien c'est bon on
repart vous dites quoi alesi jeudi
serait bien allez-vous faire marie très
bien
ok très bien je sais c'est gilbert gress
qui lui a donné sa démission si vous
avez perdu 30 pour je vais vous dire que
max et je vais vous dire effectivement
pourquoi c'est intéressant parce que la
question en fait n'est pas très bien
posé on dit faute il a garni
j'aurai donc gérer cette question alors
c'est moi la question ne fallait pas
interdire c'est quoi la question sur 30
ans et ont justement d'y interdire
est ce qu'on peut la convention a levé
la question si je suis en suspens bras
quand il est pour nous un tel message
les d'ailleurs les les états qui ont qui
n'ont pas interdit il on suspend moi si
vous voulez je le redis sur ce plateau
je n'ai aucune difficulté avec la
vaccination est aussi un homme sort de
là ils nous sortent de là oui c'est bien
mais en même temps il faut aussi voulait
on a trop menti aux français durant un
an en leur présentant des hypothèses
comme des certitudes pour que moi je me
risque à le faire ce qu'ils veulent le
faire en prendront la responsabilité
mais moi je ne le ferai pas vacciner mot
pardon je ne vais pas vous faire
vacciner
j'ai pas entendu parler vous n'allez pas
vous faire vacciner je n'ai pas faim
devant je ne suis pas dans ce jeu vous
savez que je ne suis pas dans les
catégories qui peuvent s'écouler
szabados a vendangé 46 ans j'ai 46 ans
oui mais moi ce que vous fait montré
l'étude des autorités a menacé avant
qu'ils ont besoin de toi répond un
élément intéressant vous devriez
d'ailleurs un petit peu de pression
si vous êtes plus jeune que castaldi
mais beaucoup plus jeune que si le gars
est là où c'est intéressant ce que vous
faites ce que vous pouvez pour dérégler
de des autorités davantage m e division
j'entends une voix par les gens qui ça
qu'on leur réponde je disais si vous
voulez je pense que quand on est trop
radical ou une interdiction définitive
ou la permission définitive la question
c'est qu'est-ce que je fais quand j'ai
un doute et c'est ça que l'aco la cour
de justice de l'union est venu dégager
elle est venue de gager que dans le
doubs qui a décalé mal d'autres
raisonnable il s'agit de suspendre le
temps nécessaire et c'est ça en fait
c'est pas interdit que c'est ce double
parle